[Applause]
in the blink of an eye we're winding
down on 2021. it's been a year of ups
and downs and i'd like to know how your
years been so far i'd be very happy if
you had a good 2021 and it's once again
time to look towards the future 2022 is
on the horizon and along with it are
lots of anime titles to be excited about
mostly sequels and follow-up titles we
also have a handful of strong contenders
coming our way which affirms the age-old
saying that the best is yet to come come
with me as we take a glimpse into what's
to come and let me give you a preview of
some of the shows that i've been seeing
people get very excited about let's kick
things off with bluelock
[Music]
storage okay i know what you're gonna
say another sports anime right surely
it's one with friendship lessons super
powers and a not so surprising number of
boys
friendship well one look at the poster
it should break those illusions of yours
this isn't your everyday shonen fair but
it's a prospective blockbuster that aims
to combine the sports and psychological
genres that's not to say that there
won't be any football playing here there
will be lots of it but just not in the
traditional sense after all the
prison-like facility in blue lock aims
to find japan's national team striker
when the biggest egos all over japan are
pitched against each other only the
strongest will survive blue knocks call
as a spawned anime and it delves more
into the egotistical side of sport like
it or not a lot of people are selfish
and this is a title that aims to display
the ugly side of humanity in their
desire to achieve a goal the characters
are just as interesting as well and when
i think the theme of gray morality isn't
so rare these days it's not all the time
that you see it in a sports series this
is not your haikyuu or kuroko for
football
next is my hero academia sixth season
six six seasons man i just blinked and
this thing had five sequels already time
flies doesn't it and we've come so far
from the upstart superhero title that
looked to make waves way back in 2016.
combining an inspiring story very
creative powers and a large cast of
memorable characters my hero academia
has exceeded my expectations in pretty
much every metric possible it's not a
surprise that this has become the face
of shonen anime in the late 2010s and it
doesn't look to be letting up anytime
soon things started to heat up further
this last season with a much beloved
league of villains arc but don't blink
because we're gonna have all-out war on
our hands in the sixth season it's time
for the showdown of the century as we're
set to see all heroes taking on all
villains in a battle that will decide
the fate of japan a lot of people are
excited and rightfully so this is one of
the biggest and most hyped arcs in the
manga so far and you better bring your
tissues because things are gonna get
real very soon no official dates been
announced at the time of writing but all
signs point to a 2022 release likely
somewhere in the summer
[Music]
up next is kaguya summer season three
is being critically acclaimed as one of
the best modern rom-coms but its
longevity partially surprised me just
partially in a sense that with its
popularity it would be strange to have
it just end quickly well fans can
rejoice as we can be seeing more of our
favorite super geniuses who are
hopelessly lost in their battle of love
who knew that a game of love with
overblown antics in a bid to make
someone confess could be so entertaining
fun and entertaining enough to get us
two seasons and leave the fans wanting
more kaguyasama's main selling point is
no doubt its premise and the creativity
of the jokes and scenarios that you can
find in its episodes thanks to the
energetic atmosphere and the animation
and directing there's never a dull
moment in kaguya summer and if the
previous two seasons are any indication
you can expect more of the same in the
third season too what also
differentiates it from other rom-coms is
how strong the supporting cast is the
supporting characters all have their own
characterizations and i dare say that
some of them have even outshone the main
duo in terms of fan excitement gaguya
sama fans and new watchers alike are
welcome to join in the fun as the third
season of the hit rom-com hits the
airwaves sooner than later
i've been waiting for this one can't
believe that it's been over two years
since the last season but mob psycho is
coming back i've always loved mob psycho
as a show that for me dazzles our eyes
with a visual masterpiece while wrapping
it around a very intriguing story that
has a lot of depth to it while i
wouldn't be in a rush to coronate the
first two seasons of mob psycho as anime
of the year they are surely somehow in
the top tiers of shows then and you
should really treat yourself by watching
them speaking of treats we fans have won
in the announcement of the third season
just recently mob psycho's returning for
possibly the grand finale and i can
already feel the hype as early as now
bones better not mess this one up if the
previous seasons were any indication
this one will yet again be another site
to see while no announcements on the air
day have been shown yet i fully expect
this to air sometime this 2020 and it'll
no doubt steal the spotlight the
anticipation is killing me and i'm sure
that it does for all you fans as well
the devil is a part-timer will finally
finally have its second season and it's
number six on our list
the meme is finally dead after almost a
decade of clamoring reverse isakai hit
devil is a part-timer will at least get
to continuation in anime form back in
this day people were captivated by this
story of enemies turned friends slash
lovers featuring entei isla's greatest
hero and demon lord it's a fun adventure
that captures what people just love
about these enemies into lover stories
along with a slew of charismatic and
charming characters it's reverse it's a
guy at its finest and if you haven't
seen the first season you should
definitely do it now i just find it
pretty strange that they've decided to
green light this after the controversial
ending of the light novel the fans would
have probably heard of by now still more
anime is always good and i've wanted to
see sadao emmy and chiho back in anime
form after so long complete with a new
art style to boot too stay strong no
game no life and classroom of the elite
fans if index and devil is a part-timer
can do it surely you can too i hope no
release date yet but you should expect
this title to come out within a year or
so at the halfway mark now we have
shield hero second season
[Music]
everyone's favorite edgelord hero is
back wait this isn't arifuretta well
that one will have a much anticipated
sequel coming this 2022 as well
hopefully with better animation but i
think that way more people are excited
for the second season of rising of the
shield hero now fumi and gang are back
at it again in their quest to save the
world as the ragtag team of underdogs
and their quest now takes them into
direct conflict with the rampaging
spirit tortoise and the mastermind
behind the rampaging beast the trailer
hasn't shown us much but if they're
really sticking with the novel
continuity let me just say that this
upcoming arc is a blast we'll see a lot
of action and aid to come in the form of
the strongest unlikely allies we've seen
so far something to keep you guys
excited as i am they sure do like to
keep us waiting for this one don't they
delay after delay but it looks like
we'll finally be getting it spring 22. i
just can't wait let's hope the
adaptation will be as good as the first
season
[Music]
[Applause]
just a month or so ago i made my rundown
on what i think are the best action
shows we got in the past decade i did it
in per year format and if you've watched
it make sure you do check it out by the
way you'll remember that i penned
vinland saga as my best show in 2019. i
still stand by that and i think that a
sizeable portion of you agreed that's
why it's my pleasure to have you join
the hype train for the next season of
vinland saga we've yet to see an
official announcement for the release
date for the sequel but i can see that
the excitement is off the charts villain
saga in its first season has been a
breath of fresh air in the world of
anime with its gritty atmosphere a
surprisingly realistic and educational
backdrop and some of the best character
writing i've seen for a cnn title with
what i've read of the manga vinlan saga
season 2 will have a huge shift in tone
in exchange for the fighting things
should turn more grounded and focused on
character development while we set up
for one of the best manga arcs by far
he's hoping that season two will be able
to deliver the same quality and it's up
to the anime studio to make sure that
happens there's no official announcement
on who will be animating this time round
but i'll be keeping my fingers crossed
before wit to take up the mantle once
again next we have chainsaw man
[Music]
oh man i remember when this was
announced everyone couldn't stop talking
about it and it's not hard to see why
just look at this poster and say that it
doesn't catch your attention in addition
it's not every day you see a dark action
story from shonen jump of all things one
that blows up like this one has non-stop
action brutal fights a very intense
story and profound themes chainsaw man
is what you get if you decide to take a
shonen jump series and turn the maturity
filter all the way up oh and add in a
lot of subversions too i've read the
manga and i can say that it's truly an
exhilarating ride that just refuses to
let go whether that will translate well
into anime or not is anyone's guess but
i've got full confidence that this show
will be a strong contender for anime of
the season whenever it decides to debut
i'm fully on board with the hype for
chainsaw man and you should be too i
don't know if saying expect the
unexpected would be to trite but it does
perfectly fit with this series
[Music]
it's been a long time coming for number
two on the list bleach thousand-year
blood war
[Music]
long time fans have shown an anime have
been waiting for this not too long ago
we got the confirmation that the final
arc of the thrilling series will be
getting adapted bleach has been a
cornerstone of the 2000s in anime and
the fans have been salivating to see
this final act in anime form stronger
enemies than before higher stakes than
before more intense battles and
mind-blowing bankai reveals that's what
you expect from the thousand-year blood
war arc but will its anime adaptation be
the one that will revive the same
further in the new decade we don't have
a release date for this one as yet but
i'm personally predicting a 2022 release
probably somewhere in the middle of the
year let's hope that they properly adapt
the arc this time after all shaman
king's remake due to episode constraints
leaves a lot to be designed in terms of
adaptation let's hope that bleach
doesn't fall into that same curse as its
2000 supernatural shonen brother
and guess what's number one
its attack on titan's final season
is it even a surprise to see attack on
titan's grand finale on top of this list
it is the anime that shaped much of the
landscape in the past decade and brought
in a large wave of fans it still feels
surreal talking about this after nearly
a decade we finally come to the
conclusion of the journey that gave us a
whole range of emotions from the terrors
of the early season to the joy of
triumph and the glory of salvation it's
about time for attack on titan to close
the book on what's been a legendary run
with its grand finale honestly the
ending itself has been pretty
contentious if we're gonna take a look
at manga readers reactions but i think
that it's the journey that counts it's
been a long ride and a pleasure riding
the aot train with you all and while i
feel sad to say goodbye to a masterpiece
of a series i am holding on to hope that
the anime team will cap everything off
in a finale that we won't ever forget
aot has left a landmark in the anime
industry for the past decade and the
world just can't wait to see how it will
finish this final stretch
[Music]
how's that for 2022 and beyond if you're
feeling a little bit down about life and
all i hope that this list helps shine
your way even just a little bit there's
so much more to enjoy in the coming year
and it will be a waste if you'll have to
miss those lots of blockbusters ahead
and i want to know which ones you're
looking forward to the most this was a
fun list to make and i hope that you
enjoyed this glimpse into the future if
you're up for some channel support you
can check out my two main avenues
patreon and channel memberships make
sure to also give a follow on instagram
for more updates regarding future videos
as well as some trivia or news that i'll
be posting from time to time it's been a
great ride with you and i hope see you
next time vinnie tube signing off
you